you still like that name the round mound
of rebound do you enjoy that
well i'm trying not to be as round but
that's
probably my favorite that's right that's
probably my favorite nickname of all
time
it's a good one i gotta say it's a good
one and i've been with you in person
we've hung out together and i once asked
you to explain to me
why i never would have made it in the
nba and you said i can do it very easily
conan
and all you did was slightly push your
ass
up against me and i went flying about
600 feet
and it was that was all i needed to know
my eyes light up but like a christmas
tree and i see them little skinny guys
out there
hey when i just see your skin again my
eyes got bigger sauces man
cause i knew them skinny guys had no
chance you right up that alley
you have the most powerful ass in the
world i'll say that right now
um hey i was a little worried about you
because the other day
on inside the nba it looked like you
suffered an injury you
you pulled a hammy on set is that right
i didn't pull a hammy i got a crap man
stop it i got a cramp
oh yeah okay i'm sorry it's the most
painful thing you ever gonna experience
i'm telling you if you ever get you get
cramps it's the most painful thing
well we have a clip here and it's
amazing to see
your your friends come into action to
try and save you let's take a look at
this right now
look at this in the commercial break
after our interview with chris paul
and dr o'neal talking
about it don't do it
[Laughter]
man it's unbelievable shaq
really got in there and worked that
muscle i mean he really got in there
well you know first i told you i needed
a cigarette after it was over
but hey clearly he's either the ugliest
nurse
and the biggest nurse or the ugliest
doctor and the biggest doctor in the
history of civilization
but you know what when you're in that
type of pain it doesn't matter you just
want to feel better
right so and who better than shaq with
those giant hands to come in
and help you out get you out of that
situation